[Music]
the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jenna and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes
that will be something that you'll have
on your
scale how are you guys
doing uh today I debated William Lane
Craig who's considered really the best
debat in the last century of
Christianity and I gave him a chance to
defend the Trinity and you can watch the
debate and make a decision for yourself
as to the extent to which he was able to
do so but I think you'll find that quite
frankly someone with his Eminence his
ACC memic Eminence and his standing a
75-year old man but he's been in the
game for like 50 years now half a
century in his own right couldn't do it
really he couldn't do it and he had to
keep moving to heresy uh heresy after
heresy after heresy just to avoid
logical contradiction but even when he
did that he still fell into logical
contradiction you'll see in the debate
but what I was going to say is that now
we've been doing this apologetics or
this polemics or these debates for
almost a decade now
and quite frankly in terms of the
Christian world I think William Lan
Craig quite frankly is the Pinnacle and
there is a feeling that I have that
we've pretty much done it all I know how
bad that sounds I mean we in in terms of
the UK daa the Speakers Corner guys the
people in America people who involved in
debates I think first it started with
Ahmed datat I mean he was the greatest
inspiration of all the legend of Legends
and he he was the one who started
everything up and then the current age I
think the work has been continued by
Zaki Nike who's an icon um a legend in
his own right and then inshallah you
know the people in the UK and the US
have tried to continue that work and now
there doesn't seem to be any major
opponents left however there is one wife
beater that's been U prancing around and
messing meddling around and he's been
talking and as if you know no one wants
to face him no one wants to deal with
him and he's been mentioning my name and
I've been told that actually in the Tik
Tok generation for those kinds of people
there are some people who are watching
him and the the traffic is actually uh
increased and so I never say no to a
challenge I don't I don't like to
especially not in this in this world uh
and this world of debates Etc I accept
the challenge the wife beater I do I
accept the challenge and in fact I'll
make it even more lucrative for the wife
beater what I'm going to say to the wife
Peter is that you can come and talk
about I don't need to speak to you about
Christianity because I've spoken to L
Craig about Christianity I've spoken to
the the Pinnacle the top guy in in the
industry about the Trinity and discussed
it with him the man with two phds the
man who's the best debat in the last 100
years I've spoken to him I don't need to
speak to you about that you want to make
a case against Islam I I can feel it I
can see it and there are some people who
are confident by your false confidence
have been made Confident by your false
confidence and you know
what that has to be Dash has to be
smashed and it has to be finished and it
will be finished so I accept it what's
going to happen is the
following after a condition has been met
which I'm going to spell out in a second
you can come onto this channel just like
and uh C capturing Christian did and you
can go on your own channel I give you
full permission to go on your own
channel I go on my channel we both go
simultaneously live like I did just now
with capture and
Christianity and we can speak about
whatever it is about Islam your
strongest arguments whatever it is you
want to bring up I'll me I'll respond to
you no problem I fully accept and it
doesn't have to be anything to do with
Christianity I accept your challenge
there's nothing more anyone can say now
but there's one condition only one I
accept your challenge and I will bring
you on to this channel which has
1.26 million subscribers and I don't
know something close to 400 million
views yes I'll give you all of those
privileges under one condition
Jake the Muslim
metaphysician is someone you must debate
first this man is a guy who's actually
trained me for this debate with William
Lane Craig he is in my estimation in
terms of the philosophical aspects of
the Trinity the best in the Muslim World
English speaking Muslim World probably
even the arabic speaking Muslim world I
don't know about the other languages but
he's one of the best in the world the
world class debat worldclass thinker and
he coached me for this particular debate
and this is the favor that I'm going to
put to him and I think it's only fair if
I'm going to speak to you about Islam
you should speak to him about
Christianity and the topic that you're
going to be mentioning is the Trinity
itself so if you debate him you
automatically get a pass to debate
me yes and you can come and speak about
Islam and talk about anything you like
and it'll be a quick turnaround quick
enough I'll give you a link and you can
go uh live on your channel this is a
great opportunity for you will you
must that a secular for go there will
leaves those jokes for another time
maybe but would you must the courage to
accept Jake the Muslim metaphysician
challenge if you do and if you're able
to to do that then you will be facing me
I'll be next and it will be on this
channel on your channel no problem at
all there is nobody in the Christian
World there is no human being in the
Christian world that can make a good
defense of falsehood I'm not saying the
whole religion is false there's aspects
of Christianity which are true and there
is no one in the Christian World which
can can have a good argument against
truth
nobody not you not anybody
else and that's the bottom line I expect
I'm waiting for your response and that's
all I have to
say Hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more